qu'est ce que t'es tu joues et pourquoi
dis moi que c'est pas vrai
je crois qu'ils veulent qu'on vienne les
trophées
ces images proviennent
de fouilles archéologiques à travers le
monde des civilisations disparues qui
n'ont eu aucun contact entre elles
pourtant le même pictogrammes apparaît
dans chacune mésopotamienne aztèque
jusqu'aux grottes préhistoriques en
france
c'est une carte du ciel non
pas une carte
attention
promesse a eu lie les forêts
jusqu'où iriez-vous
pour avoir vos réponses
que seriez-vous prêts verts
remettez vous lier ça
et quoi j'ai chopé un senior dames anse
un signal à km à l'ouest peu d'humour
dans ses labos s'être
laissé convaincre
tuez tous vous oui
poule 3
où aller